[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Kyle solar AKA
Cyril Karn who stars in and or we're
gonna be talking spoilers so make sure
you're caught up on Anna before you
watch his interview Kyle how you doing
today I'm good dude how you doing I'm
doing great it's great to see you
um Beautiful piano by the way I don't
know if you got any playing in before
this interview but very nice thanks man
it's not mine but I look at it long
enough you know with admiration
love it um so this is so exciting
because like you you got to tell me what
it's like being in a Star Wars project
did you feel the most pressure on this
project than anything you've done in
your crew before and did you even feel
nerves on set
it's certainly the biggest thing I've
ever been a part of I mean I will say
though that when we were filming it it
was November 2020 so like everybody on
set was just like super happy to be
alive and like working
so weirdly the nerves of undertaking
something like
um
Andor and Star Wars it it didn't really
feel as
um nervous as it does now
to be honest to to have it being
released into the world and being
embraced by the family of Star Wars and
fans and everything and
um but we also had an amazing showrunner
in Tony Gilroy who just I mean his Mo
from the very beginning was like we're
just doing another show here
we're just doing this like
socio-political drama Thriller family
weird drama thing at the same time it
just so happens to be in space
so we all really just kind of
had that mentality thank God because I
think
I think if I
by the time
all right like yeah it's not a spoiler
but by the time we were forming a kind
of episode 12 moment
um I hadn't really seen in Cyril's
Journey many
stock like old school like Star Wars
characters and there was this huge group
of people Milling about
a massive scene and all of a sudden they
parted and there was just this line of
Stormtroopers and I like I like lost my
[ __ ] a little bit because when it that's
when I kind of got the nerves was like
oh yeah
yeah yeah this is what we're doing
um but yeah luckily before that no now
it's interesting you'd mentioned just
the nerves of it being out now do are
you somebody will you go look up the
Star Wars Reddit look at fan reactions
reviews or do you kind of think it's
better to avoid that yeah it's like my
nightly practice man like right before I
close my eyes I see what everybody in
the world says about me like
no no
okay okay I like I really try to stay as
far away from that as possible for
my own mental health and yeah and and
not trying to start any like chat room
brawls you know yeah okay so you're not
hiding behind like a Reddit handle cool
so well I saw that yeah
okay okay all right um so also if people
look at your acting experience you have
a huge amount of theater experience was
there any moments in this show that
something that would come in handy for
playing this character
saying Tony's words man I mean like I I
really was surprised when I first read
those scripts back in like March
February 2020 I was like wow this is
like
this is the dude who wrote Michael
Clayton this is the dude who's like he's
been writing amazing dramas and
thrillers for decades and
it shows and it's it's really
psychological writing
and um and certainly like the way that
he has pitched Andor is much more
about the people it's much more human
focused and as a result like you're in
in my experience of Cyril like he goes
home to meet his mother and that kind of
turns into this weird
after Pinter play you know like it's
there's so much
in what is not said
and so I I think the writing was you
know man yeah like on caliber with
anything that I've done on stage
yeah and you mentioned to him meaning
going back to his mom's I mean where
we're seeing him there is that would you
say absolute hell for him even just
being there
it's like
you know I mean
everybody's got family right I mean but
imagine having to go back and live with
your family like as an adult after
losing your job
um really unceremoniously
um yeah that's his absolute like
um is it Nader is that the word the
opposite of like an apex I'm not gonna
try to sound smart but it's the lowest
of the low for him man it's like yeah
couldn't get any worse like that that
relationship Dynamic
um which I'm so grateful exists
uh on screen is so much an explanation
of why cereal is the way that he is and
why
he is so
um
drawn to the movement of fascism that
that the Empire represents you have a
very constrictive restrictive and
oppressive home life
with one dominating figure that happens
to be his mother where nothing are good
enough and
literally everything that Cyril Prides
in himself about you know his uniforms
and the way he looks and his high level
of Standards you go back and his mom's
going like that's what you're wearing
for your job like you see how to trickle
down has like been morphed and twisted
and turned into this like
desire for power and control on a larger
scale
yeah and it's interesting too because
you mentioned that upbringing he's had
and again we've already seen some of
this with getting more hints about his
upbringing meeting his mom and his home
life but did you also go an extra step
and make a whole character backstory for
Karn when you were kind of deciding how
he exactly is this man who's also
obsessed with just upholding Law and
Order yeah totally totally
um I always tend to do that
and I spoke with I spoke with Tony at
the very beginning we're kind of like
okay because I really wanted to know
like why he was the way he was but what
he had written on the page I was like
wow this is so like unique for a kind of
what seems to be a Star Wars villain
and um and we talked about his backstory
and his mom and he's like maybe he meets
his mom and I was like yes and bring her
in and
um but what I what I also did was I mean
some of these stories are just now so
within our Collective Consciousness but
I went back to the period between the
first world war and the second world war
and the stories of people who got swept
up in these movements
without fully understanding what they
were agreeing to or realizing it way too
late
and I mean they're like
yeah I mean there are hundreds of awful
stories like that you know just innocent
yeah just you know
yeah totally and it's interesting you're
talking about that going back to history
but also I was wondering is there any
specific characters in just Media or art
that inspired your portrayal of corn
like was there anything you were kind of
drawing from
not really I I kind of just focused on
what Tony had written in our discussions
and I trusted that that was that was
kind of enough I mean
yeah yeah and then the kind of
historical stuff I didn't
I like I like using lots of different
things for inspiration but I find that
sometimes like
you know using other characters is is
kind of useful for like an audition
scenario you're like I need a like a
Lincoln I need a foot in to like
something and you're like oh it's kind
of like this character maybe I do
something like that and then you wind up
in the middle ground of like sharing
different things with that character and
taking bits and leaving bits but
but with this I like
I didn't really do that I did a bunch of
other stuff like other weird [ __ ] but
yeah
yo that that's good and that's great
advice for just auditioning in general
and interesting too because again you're
talking about how good the script is and
with character and I think what's
fascinating a lot of people were talking
about was with serial chasing Andor and
failing miserably
um how traumatic was this really form
especially seeing some of his co-workers
die like what what was that trauma level
you think for him in that moment
like 11 out of 10.
I think you know
you know in the lead up to landing on
ferrics you you see him being thrust
into a position of authority where he
sees these mercenaries basically he's
like oh [ __ ] like
is that this could get like really real
have I gone too far is this worthy of
the cause that I feel in my heart and in
my head is this tactic like is this
worthy and necessary
and then throughout that whole sequence
of them running around trying to find
gassy and I like it just settles in
further and further like this is this is
bad this this we've gone way too far and
then yeah like seeing co-workers
being
effectively I mean you in one sense
could say like killed by Cyril he's
there to like protect and uphold his
loyalty to his servicemen who were
killed by Cassian
and then he undertakes this kind of
horribly botched Mission and winds up
killing three or four of his own guys so
like
yeah man he's had a
he's had a complete
um
Fall From Grace and that's one of the
things that kind of attracted me about
the characteristic within the first
three episodes he's got this like super
high and then the lowest of the low I
mean yeah opposite ends of the spectrum
and then it kind of like
I don't know it kind of goes from there
yeah and with you saying it kind of goes
from there it's interesting that when we
see him at home he's still looking at
this projection of Cassian so I want to
know
if you can get us into the mindset of
obsession still there with Cassie what
what is his motivation behind that why
is he still thinking about him
he's thinking about calcium because like
that is the only fire that can like keep
him alive I think while he's in his
childhood bedroom where there's only
like was it like four seconds of light a
day that like captures like that part of
the apartment block and this
claustrophobic a horrible container with
his mother and
he found purpose in Cassian like he went
above and beyond what he thought he
could achieve and yeah he did completely
[ __ ] it up like an easily hardcore but
at the same time like it pushed him into
a new level into a new zone of being
which
he had always thought he was capable of
I think but didn't have the opportunity
and so I don't know you know how
sometimes there's like maybe something
that you've lost or you know whether
it's a person or relationship or a
I don't know I'm not sure I don't know I
don't know like a toy or like you know
sometimes like you you'll keep that
wound open because keeping that wound
open like doesn't allow it to heal
because if you allow it it kind of goes
back into the memory and takes on a
different kind of meaning but if you
keep it open it remains raw and it
actually propels you to like
to feel well that was the right choice
no I know that that was the right choice
like I'm not a screw-up like my mother
says and
and you know the corporate security says
like I know I was onto something and I
think he does really really feel
intuitively that there's something
different about Cassian right he's just
on
he's on a level and also represents
something like the complete opposite of
what Cyril is
girl's eyes like is this freewheeling
dude who can kind of do whatever he
wants and literally like
free and easy stealing and getting by by
the seat of his pants and Cyril's world
is so rigid and constricted that he just
is so like how can this guy exist and
get away with it like it's obsessive
yeah for sure and it's interesting
because we see that state of mind he's
in and then now where we last see him
getting this miserable job in a cubicle
for fuel Purity so
is can you kind of just give us maybe a
little tease what might come next in the
sense of like is there like you know a
beast waiting to come out is he just
gonna sit there and lay back like do you
is there gonna be crazy stuff happening
is what I'm getting at stuff goes down
man
stuff goes down
um yeah hashtag safe Cyril
um like say ferris like I believe in him
uh he's gonna make it but he's he's
gonna suffer a little bit more at first
and I think you know the trajectory of
it is really like a huge rise massive
fall a kind of plateau of being shunted
into this like
fuel Purity kind of like observation in
a no-name nondescript location in course
he then has a
well let's just say as you were as you
were suggesting like he doesn't let
Cassian go and then he attracts some
interest
from another character at a higher level
at the ISB
crosses path with that person and gains
a new fire to kind of restart the whole
Pursuit oh I like that that that's
exciting and
last question I have for you before I
let you go Kyle is I I what I love about
this character the most is that he has
Clone Trooper action figures in his room
um so I was gonna ask you Kyle if you
had Star Wars action figures in your
room who would you have up there who
would be sitting in there oh man I mean
like wow
wow I would definitely have the like the
end or like scooter thing oh okay like I
would definitely that was my favorite
vehicle in all of Star Wars
um
and I wasn't you know I was a huge Han
Solo man like hell yeah my guy growing
up but
I think with my my two older brothers so
we just watched those films religiously
it was like Han and Boba Fett were like
oh yeah that's where everybody's weren't
they I mean they were like these like
Mythic creations and yeah a hundred
percent
um I love that answer everybody watch
Kyle crush it and Andor every Wednesday
on Disney plus Kyle thank you so much
for joining me today I hope to talk to
you in the future thanks dude likewise